we had a lot of confusion I'm still
confused this is cool none durwood's
bachelor finale and it's time for roses
and rose eh
hi everybody it's the end Oh
Colton Underwood season of The Bachelor
is over and I am Lauren Zima here to
recap with you the very final piece and
guys if there's anything we've learned
from this season of The Bachelor the
fence jumping season of The Bachelor
it's that we've got to be ready for
anything right so I'm trying something
new tonight box wine what are the
advantages portable use it on the go
less breakable than glass let's give it
a whirl
oh and speedy we've got to be fast on
the go we never know when we might have
to jump a fence and run haha okay
everybody so let me know big question of
the night do you prefer boxed wine I
don't prefer it but I am enjoying it
right now let's get to it so the theme
of the night was culminating in
confusion everyone and culminating in
confusion each start with C just like
Goldman Cassie I was baffled by so many
of the interactions between Cassie and
Colton tonight and we are gonna get into
it also to start things off : says I
don't know if she can be in love with me
which is a real reversal from what he
had said to Chris Harrison on Monday
night isn't it when he said Cassie is
definitely in love with me already I'm
confused don't don't don't drink every
time you're confused I didn't want to
end the other night like it ended then
Colton goes to Cassie and tells her I
broke up with tisha I broke up with
Hannah I'm here just for you and what
does she say
that's what it felt like right she said
things like I'm so nervous right now I'm
so nervous right now and this is crazy
this is crazy and this is really crazy
really crazy and my personal favorite
you can't please that I needed Cassie to
tell Colton her feelings for him in this
moment right that's why I was so
confused she seemed to be in shock I am
just like really trying to let the shock
of this all like kind of fade off so I
can like actually saying right I'm
saying something she seemed to maybe be
not too happy about it all I thought if
she was in love with Colton like he
thought she was and he'd come to her and
said I've dumped the other women I just
want to be here for you wouldn't she say
oh my god I love you it was so happy it
was so excited what a relief what a show
of love I couldn't be more elated we
didn't get that did we what do you guys
think of Cassie's reaction to Colton's
big news that he was only there for her
what was going for him I feel like in
the future that can make you resent me
too Cassie goes on to say you know she
doesn't want him to give up on things
she doesn't want him to resent her and
you feel like I think % sure about it
she really seems to be trying to get out
of this doesn't she but they're kissing
and see you shaking I'm like shaking now
I've been wondering what they have in
common maybe that they both shake so
cheers to being confused because now
they're together I think did we even get
an answer but did they get back together
they never said that I'm still confused
I'm sorry that I mean we're confused
I have a pen a pencil ran away
we're gonna get through this whole box
okay and then she says it's not normal
nope you signed up for a TV show I don't
know what I'm ready for
I feel good right now I don't I'm so
overwhelmed I can't even believe I get I
can't believe this is happening Sam what
is happening seriously are they a couple
on Monday night Chris Harrison said it
was a bachelor first The Bachelor had
never not had any women in his life
before and tonight I'm still not sure
that he does have something that I'm
gonna share with you guys yeah I don't
think you're gonna be expecting but I am
no longer a virgin
so then Cassie needs Colton's family and
do not drink every time Cassie says
she's nervous we're really getting
through this this wine is too easy to
pour it's gonna be a problem it's just
one button
what precision I can't believe I live
before this 50 gold medals this is not a
sponsor but how do you even get a gold
medal in wine that's a sport I could do
smarts okay I don't even know how they
got it and I'm like I couldn't do that
this wine I can do that I can get a gold
medal weird amount of confidence much
like Colton's belief in Cassie's
feelings for him anyway
I went from 30 women to 0 then now 2 1
do you feel with Cassie are you in love
with her are you falling in love with
her do you see that I'm in love with
Cassie Cole's family is questioning
things then Cassie is crying about
meeting Cole's family oh my god no more
tears please got enough last night and
then Colton says all I know all I know
is that when I'm around Cassie I feel
great you should know more and then the
dad says well we've all been wondering
which is and you don't think any part of
that was wanting what you can't have no
oh God and then we got dad tears we got
dad tears dad tears alert more tears and
this time the tears were dad tears I
can't handle dad tears you guys pause
for dad tears I know how you are when
you're in love I've seen it you look
great
I suppose in a moment of some sort of
clarity cool decides to Cassie I just
wanted to tell you I appreciate you
taking this day by day with me and
there's nobody who I'd rather be with
right now
can you then Kuhn said that this has
been worth every moment it's been worth
every moment and and and every minute
every minute so moments and minutes and
days by days The Bachelor time will go
on except not really because they're not
really on the show they've taken down
the walls of the show but they're still
going on dates and total show fashion
and we're gonna get a fantasy suite okay
Cassie says like I do see it getting
there where where are we going I don't
know where we're going anymore
I'm on the train of confusion heading
down the tunnel of what the heck to the
land of the bizarre I don't know where
we're going what is there it's a very
existential here on the bachelor finale
and then Cass finishes it off with quote
however we leave this I want to be all
in yeah what does that mean do you want
to be all in your relationship if you're
out of it do you want to be all in out
of it look I'm saying all this but I
really still love the episode you guys
it was a lot of fun and Colton and
Cassie do seem happy together now so
we're gonna get to that right what do
you think do they seem happy together
now let me know and I know you might get
emotional right now dad oh you know the
whole time okay then some of my favorite
parts come about they're still talking
around their relationship like as if
other women are still there I wondered
if that was part of it they're so used
to the framework of the show and the
construct of the conversation but even
though no other women were part of it
and they could just be themselves they
were still like on this like Bachelor
day with this like food that they're not
gonna eat and like all the cameras are
around and they were still sort of
speaking in generalities instead of just
getting into their specific feelings
then the fantasy suite happens and what
do you guys think was the fantasy suite
a turning point for them I feel that it
was I think they needed that off-camera
time and we got some off-camera time but
did we get some sex I don't know at
first they jumped in and they were just
so excited about how comfortable the bed
was oh my gosh and I was like here we've
been sleeping on a bad mattress has it
been a blow-up mattress has been an air
mattress for Colton has been a street of
Portugal on the other side of a fence
we've been sleeping I don't know but
they were excited I would have been
excited to do other things if I was the
26 year old version I'm nobody
interrupts this oh my god they're gonna
go into the fantasy suite and they make
this big joke about getting Dee Mike
[Music]
and so
[Music]
: I'm calling you out here you took off
your own mic before you jump the fence
you know how to dean bike yourself you
know how to deep mic yourself it's not
even that hard if you've never done it
you could figure that out it's like a
clothespin it's like a chip bad clip I
love chips okay so they do their thing
in the morning after we get one more
cold and Underwood shower for old times
sake cheers to that
mm-hmm I feel very good with you still
no so
we had an amazing night we did what was
best for our relationship and we grew as
a couple which is one more confusing
thing for old times sake what do you
guys think did they have sex that night
in the fantasy suites I don't think they
did but I do think they've done it back
I know and Cassie said I think at one
point correct me if I'm wrong I cast my
cap still hurts
whatever that means I think they were
trying to make that like sort of a
sexual comment maybe but like for all we
know her calf was hurting from careening
down that cliffside which seemed
dangerous can we stop with the dangerous
dates good lord bungee jumping skydiving
and cliff careening picnicking near a
cliff and like I'm shocked you know and
died this season and glass should we
bring him out okay Cassie and Colton are
now on the live finale and man oh man
did they look like the table Oh a
wedding cake didn't they Cassie was in
Bridal white looking beautiful Colton
was in a classic suit and tie looking
handsome no weird ties for quilting
tonight I thought that he might propose
the way they were looking and how happy
they seemed what did you guys think did
you expect a proposal on the live finale
I thought we had a chance we're super oh
what a turnaround I mean this is a 180
from confusion to clarity what did you
think of Coleman Cassie's relationship
they seemed comfortable and confidently
are you planning on getting engaged it's
definitely something we've talked about
and they are definitely talking about
getting engaged Wow again a lot of clear
communication great
[Music]
video because I have absolutely sucked
sharing my feelings and then you know we
are watching Cassie and Colton happy
couple weekends and we are watching
Cassie and Colton watch themselves watch
Cassie I don't know why you know what
this seemed like a good moment for a
vlog I don't know why we didn't have it
should have logged did you lose your
virginity heading into the fantasy suite
I wasn't thinking about anything other
than fighting for our relationship and I
know I've been very open and candid
about my virginity but since there are
two of us now in this relationship it's
something that we're gonna keep to
ourselves : gives the answer but ashley
i kennedy has given in the past which is
that now the two people are involved he
doesn't feel comfortable getting into it
and you know what on the one hand as a
fan I felt like he brought us onto this
journey with him he introduced the fact
he was a virgin I'm Becca Cooper in
season he brought that up we didn't ask
him to and we've been on this story with
him the whole time so we deserve an
ending to the story a last chapter to
the book but I also understand the
Cassie if somebody who didn't feel great
about the fact that she'd had sex before
and so Colton is being respectful for
about not getting into it so ultimately
I get it but I don't get it do you know
what I mean do you get it what do you
think now am I being confusing how do
you guys feel do you think that we
should have gotten an answer from Colton
about the virginity thing I mean
ultimately at the end of the day look
he's not gonna stay a virgin forever
until he dies so like he's gotta lose
forget somebody does not he's like who
cares we know the answer is gonna be yes
or it is yes oh wow sorry I really am
going on a tangent there all the
confusion is confusing me mmm I think
it's time we introduced our new
bachelorette
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Hannah B let's get into something that
is 100% for sure
Hanabi yes is the Bachelorette and she
looked great I loved her outfit I love a
red cape moment I wore one when I was
covering and we have graduated from
vlogs to FaceTime are you serious about
it we see how to be find out that she is
the Bachelorette which I'm not sure
we've ever seen a lead get the news
before I'm telling you
and so they recorded Hanabi and Chris
Harrison facetiming Wow we are moving on
into the 21st second third century here
on The Bachelor franchise but I will say
that I thought the face scent was like a
little long and awkward like they could
have edited it down a little bit here's
a lot of silence hey do you want some
coffee I'm looking for the creamer I'm
the Bachelorette what no I'm looking for
the creamer I'm the Bachelorette are you
okay
the creamer the bachelor I think he's
saying I'm the Bachelorette do you know
where the creamer is washing over the
cream room no Bachelorette tad tad
Bachelet oh okay yeah Laurette we're
actually gonna start your show right now
you're about to meet your first five men
we are continuing the tradition of
meeting as some of the first contestants
live which started with Rachel Lindsay
wondrous things do you like doing this I
don't need it
like we're gonna see them again during
the episodes anyways and then I'm gonna
forget them by that points like I don't
need it I don't care I'll take that oh
man we got five guys and one of them I
think may have thought he was gonna have
Hannah gee he has the Bachelorette
because he wrapped we're gonna be we
should see him with the pantry
appropriate so I just wanted to say when
they said it was you it was a pleasant
surprise
now I'm staying here look you straight
in the eyes all the other dudes got me
feeling so stressed so I say all aboard
hot mess Express this time Hannah be
gave out a rose we had not done that
before
I don't know when to
actually and she kind of struggled to
give out that rose it took a minute it
took a minute give out the rose I'm
gonna be give up throws give up the rose
give out the rose give out the wrong
look all my love to Hanna beat I just
think I said this I think she needs to
condemns her sentences a little bit but
I think she is super genuine I love to
seeing her turn around from sort of a
villainized person to beloved southern
belle she really persevered on coldest
season I think she's gonna have like a
lot of kooky fun crazy things to say
what do you guys think of Hanna B is our
new bachelorette do you approve of this
decision bachelor nation we one thing we
cannot do we cannot drink every time
Hannah says roll tide we cannot do that
it's like the new Becca ku friends do
the damn thing and I don't want to do
the roll tide thing I don't even know
what it means
Oh all right everybody that was this
season of The Bachelor oh you guys I'm
sad it's over I love you guys so much
but we got a crazy outcomes of things
that had never happened in the history
of the show before a burgeoned bachelor
a fence jump we didn't get a proposal we
got a new bachelorette this is the 15th
season of The Bachelorette and Hannah B
is the first Bachelorette ever to like
not be in the top four and be chosen so
that's exciting we have so much to look
forward to I love you guys so much and
don't worry there will still be episodes
of roses and rose' in between bachelor
and bachelorette Cece and I are not
going anywhere we love you too much and
auntie and a little shameless plug for
myself oh I am now on cameo yes here's
the thing I got an email from them in
October an email address I never checked
so if you guys were wanting to buy
cameos from me I'm so sorry that I
missed out but I'm on there now so you
can check it out and please watch me on
eat see live working on some new
exciting things there and again roses
and rosy is not going anywhere so love
you guys all so much leave your comments
and questions below and know that we are
still here for you there's no confusion
[Music]
tell me something Lauren are you happy
with Hanna B or did you want someone
more boring that southern girls real
sassy we're falling faster than tisha
and Colton D from the sky and then he
dumped your and he said goodbye
tell me something JC I am so happy with
Hanna B and for Colton and Cassie even
though they were so confusing
there's no conclude consider we're
falling faster than cold tears from his
face they poured down when he left hand
G in that space the season is over we
drink lots of wine but we have to move
on there is cold in a virgin we didn't
find out we're far from the fence
[Music]